[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
nous avons décidé que créer notre propre
monnaie en l'émettant aux particuliers aux
résidents qui ont été touchés par la
pandémie et ce serait le meilleur le
meilleur scénario, puis cela arriverait
aux entreprises parce que  nous arriverions
là où c'était un système fermé et seules
les seules entreprises locales
accepteraient l'argent
évidemment, il y a des restrictions qui s'y
appliquent, vous ne pouvez pas acheter, vous savez, du
tabac, de l'alcool ou de la loterie, ce genre
de choses,
mais tout type d'autres biens réels, cela
fonctionne essentiellement comme de l'argent
[Musique]
c'est comme une typographie des années 1870 et
c'est  la presse à imprimer qui a été
utilisée pour imprimer nos journaux, puis dans
les années 1930, c'est en fait la
presse à imprimer qui a été utilisée pour
fabriquer l'argent en bois pendant la
Grande Dépression, donc vous savez quand cette
idée est venue, nous sommes venus  ici, nous
avons une personne qui sait comment
faire fonctionner cette chose en toute sécurité
[Musique]
nous la mettons dans nos sacs bancaires et nous pouvons
soit vous savez la ramener en ville
et l'encaisser
[Musique]
il semble que vous ayez  point de fierté parce que
c'est lié à notre histoire et parce que vous
savez que nous sommes vous savez que nous sommes américains, nous
sommes fiers d'être indépendants et
de prendre soin des choses nous-mêmes
[Musique]